[Musica]
[Applauso]
dopo tre anni di direzione dello storico
festival lgbt cui torinese e dopo quasi
dieci a realizzare pensare e scrivere
film mi sono chiesta come fosse cambiato
il mio rapporto con il cinema
ero passata da gestire un singolo film a
gestire la programmazione di quasi un
centinaio
il film e corpo diceva pasolini il film
nasce e si incontra con il proprio
pubblico
il film è una riflessione è un prodotto
del pensiero che è limitato all'interno
di una realtà sociale ma allo stesso
tempo e potenziato il film nell'incontro
con il proprio pubblico crea riflessioni
crea nuovi concetti secondo le teorie
dell'asia né si crea in noi di fronte
alle immagini in movimento una sorta di
automa spirituale le immagini in
movimento investono la nostra corteccia
cerebrale e creano nuovi processi
mentali e intellettivi
siamo di fronte alla possibilità di
creare nuovi concetti una sorta di shock
intellettuale bene un festival è un
luogo in cui è possibile vedere
centinaia di film ci sono migliaia di
spettatori e quindi una fucina
inequivocabilmente di nuovo pensiero
luogo di creazione di conoscenza
condivisa e organica un festival ha
quindi una potenzialità enorme rispetto
alla transizione nella riflessione del
pensiero umano ma un festival di sua
natura intersezionale ovvero lgbt cui
che tipo di potenzialità a che cosa vuol
dire intersezionale questa è la prima
domanda si usa molto spesso nel panorama
culturale e politico però in maniera
indebita volte nell 89 kimberly criscio
lo introduce all'interno dei suoi studi
attivista e fondatrice dell'african
americani policy forum per la columbia
university intersezionale età
la co presenza identitaria per le donne
di colore di una discriminazione di
doppio livello ovvero sessista e
razzista al contempo queste donne sono
inserite all'interno di una sorta di
intersection l'incrocio e sono deboli in
quell'incrocio questa parola è stata
usata all'interno di altri contesti
naturalmente per le teorie queer che
sono naturalmente le teorie che sono
relative a tutto ciò che eccentrico
tutto ciò che fuori alla norma
codificata egemonica in qualche modo ma
anche negli studi di genere negli studi
femministi
l'utilizzo di questa parola è molto
importante perché ci racconta la
compresenza di differenti
discriminazioni che agiscono tutti
insieme in maniera molteplice ma a volte
in queste intersezioni in questi luoghi
di debolezza dove ci sono identità che
non sono forse riconosciute o a volte
non sono nemmeno riconoscibili vi è una
forza le terre di mezzo sono luoghi
liberi dai vincoli e sono luoghi molto
più potenti e perché liberi dai vincoli
in questa marea di immaginare inter
sezionali nelle pieghe della fantasia
forse possiamo trovare nuove visioni
forse possiamo trovare nuove utopie
carlo ginsburg diceva nel formaggio i
vermi la storia normalmente viene
raccontata dai vincitori
le minoranze reali e culturali non hanno
spazio che cosa vuol dire allora un
festival che è potenzialmente mostra dei
film che sono fatti da soggetti
normalmente non rappresentati e liberi
dalla distribuzione classica e dalla
produzione meccanismi che a volte li
costringono un festival di questo genere
ci propone visioni non colonizzate i
festival internazionali da cannes a
berlino venezia mostrano dei luoghi in
cui è possibile avere immaginari non
convenzionali possibilità di andare
oltre con la fantasia ma la visione le
visioni cinematografiche da chi sono
date normalmente qual è la da chi è data
la visione che normalmente noi fruiamo
donne audiovisivo della dea da dei dati
sconcertanti
intanto la struttura presenta
nel cinema femminile è solo una parte
della struttura presentazione del genere
femminile nella società che non è
presente nel top management dei settori
privati non è presente nei cda
naturalmente delle amministrazioni
pubbliche non è presente nella ricerca
scientifica inoltre ci dice l'unesco e
report unesco che la creatività non è un
genere neutro la creatività in quanto
genere femminile o maschile e la sua
discriminazione solo parte di una
disparità più generale tanto è vero che
global gender gap del 2016 indica
l'italia al 100 27esimo posto su 144 per
disparità salariale tra donne e uomini
inoltre a questo dobbiamo aggiungere
anche i dati della mappa
dell'intolleranza che è un progetto
dell'osservatorio dei nuovi diritti
italiani in questo progetto possiamo
osservare alcune dati molto importanti
in questi dati si evidenza come
attraverso la geolocalizzazione e
l'estrazione di tweet è possibile vedere
secondo sei gruppi differenti composti
da donne migranti omosessuali ebrei
musulmani e diversamente abili come si
accumula nei tweet d'odio contro di loro
si è balzati di 4 punti percentuali dal
2017 al 2018 dal 32 45 per cento al
36,45 per cento l'odio online e molto
etero patriarcale inoltre possiamo anche
riportare i dati dell'european network
la 88 per cento dei film a finanziamento
pubblico sono diretti da uomini
il 79 per cento a finanziamento pubblico
per la rai sono diretti da uomini solo
il 9,2 per cento dei film che arrivano
al cinema e sono distribuiti nelle sale
e diretto da donne questi dati ci
raccontano un panorama davvero
sconcertante e ci si chiede dove si può
trovare dei nuovi spiragli nuove visioni
dove possono trovare voci le minoranze
ecco io vi ho portato una serie di film
divisioni che a mio avviso raccontano in
maniera più genere
nuovi spiragli in qualche modo visivi
nuove utopie in the nightingale di
jennifer kent che è stato presentato
all'ultimo festival di venezia
possiamo vedere claire giovane detenuta
irlandese che cammina verso le cucine
dove sta scontando la propria pena
portare nel tra le braccia il proprio
bambino
gli sta cantando una nenia con dolcezza
a un certo punto però con un secco
stacco di montaggio vediamo un coltello
apparire e in questo momento la regista
ci chiede in maniera risoluta
sei pronto ribaltamento di campo da una
madonna rassicurante e materna a grazia
che si trasforma mascolinità e violenza
nightingale è un rapper e wengè che è
stato appunto presentato nella nel
festival di venezia che ha ottenuto un
enorme successo e un è un racconto di un
riscatto sociale in cui claire una
giovane detenuta si allea dopo aver
perso tutto il proprio bambino
il il proprio marito e anche la propria
dignità perché è stata stuprata
ripetutamente da un crudelissimo
ufficiale inglese si allea con un attivo
e in questo percorso cercano una sorta
di riscatto sociale verso altri lidi
nella loro najb it e billie in attivo e
claire la protagonista la giovane
detenuta irlandese nell'allora
intersezionale ta della lotta
nell'allora unione tra gli oppressi
stanno lottando contro una visione che
non è la loro
vi ho portato anche un altro esempio
quello di erika lust erika l'asse a una
giovane regista che produce film porno
in d nel 77 nata a stoccolma decide di
trasferirsi a barcellona dopo gli studi
in scienze politiche e decide di
occuparsi di pornografia lo fa cercando
di scardinare i cliché della pornografia
classica e lo fa attraverso una visione
post femminista
lo fa attraverso l'audiovisivo perché
l'inconscio agisce più della parola
scritta come ci può dire l'homo videns
di sartori per esempio
non siamo resistenza di fronte
all'immagine non ci sono filtri
l'immagine arriva in maniera molto
potente erika lust decide di non
utilizzare quelli che sono i cliché
della pornografia tradizionale e non
lavora sulla co azione meccanica a
ripetere dei corpi lavora su soggetti
che non sono più oggetti e soprattutto
su desideri inno mercificati corpi non
mercificati ci fa vedere la possibilità
di un desiderio sovversivo e soprattutto
una gerarchia in cui il piacere maschile
non è al primo posto un altro film che
vi volevo assolutamente portare è
l'opera prima di essere stiano mauri
interpretato dal marito di sebastiano
filippo timi
in questo film una casalinga frustrata
cerca di uscire dalla propria gabbia
d'oro e lo fa nel momento in cui ad un
certo punto scopre di non essere più una
donna ma un uomo scoprendo questa
metamorfosi inaspettata decide di in
qualche modo fuggire e lo fa dopo
essersi innamorata della propria
migliore amica in cui somma in questo in
questo modo sebastiano mauri decide di
creare una sorta di spazio narrativo che
anche l'inconscio e gioca con una lente
d'ingrandimento sulla società italiana
raccontandoci in maniera completamente
diversa e con i codici del mio queer
sinema del maestro to dance del
melodramma la possibilità di un
dispositivo di fuga dalla realtà
in questa narrazione che diventa
inconscio è possibile naturalmente
ritrovare una nuova unione tra il
femminile il maschile e in qualche modo
ri disegnare trame di desideri
socialmente ammissibili queste
previsioni ci raccontano di tre
possibilità tre ricerche grazie all'arte
cinematografica che in qualche modo
rendono possibile nuove utopie radici di
visioni future appunto in questo spazio
estetico e sensuale il genere viene
messo in crisi e mettendo in crisi il
genere mettiamo in crisi anche la
società istituita rigidamente su questa
impostazione
questi registi con una colt una forte
cultura femminista intersezionale ci
mostrano chiaramente una via e lo fanno
attraverso film che come abbiamo detto
prima ci aiutano a creare nuovi concetti
creando nuovi concetti abbiamo nuovi
orizzonti e questi nuovi orizzonti
seppur lontani sono comunque delle
traiettorie transitare verso il futuro è
sicuramente difficile e molto spesso ci
rendiamo conto che parti della società
non sono pronte ad affrontare questa
transizione come dimostrano i diritti
lgbt qui i diritti delle dei migranti
naturalmente ma anche delle delle donne
degli uomini transessuali non siamo
ancora pronti
forse in parte perché il cinema con
grande forza e con lungimiranza ci sta
già mostrando la via
grazie
[Applauso]